Heute Morgen geht es dem Präsidenten sehr
gut.
Hinter mir sind einige Mitglieder des
Ärzteteams des Präsidenten. Äh,
die ich vorstellen möchte. äh.
Dr. Sean
Dooley  Blaylock-Infektionskrankheit
Dr. Wes Campbell-Infektionskrankheit
Dr. John Hodgson Anästhesie
Major Kurt Klein Army Nurse Commander
Megan Nasworthy
Navy Nurse Leutnant Juliana Lavopa
Navy Nurse Lieutenant Lieutenant
Commander John Shea
Klinischer Apotheker und nicht bei
uns anwesend sind Lieutenant Beth Carter
Lieutenant Maureen Meehan, beide Navy
Nurses und  dr. jesse show jetzt
direktor unseres programms für exekutive
medizin,
wie gestern berichtet, nach einer konsultation mit
dieser gruppe
empfahl ich, den präsidenten als vorsichtsmaßnahme
zu walter reed zu bringen,
um eine
hochmoderne überwachung und jegliche pflege zu gewährleisten
, die er möglicherweise
nur 72 stunden nach beginn benötigt  diagnose jetzt die
erste woche von covid und ein teil  Insbesondere die Tage 7 bis
10 sind die kritischsten
, um den wahrscheinlichen Verlauf dieser
Krankheit
zu diesem Zeitpunkt zu bestimmen. Das Team und ich sind
äußerst zufrieden mit den Fortschritten, die der
Präsident am
Donnerstag gemacht hat. Er hatte leichten Husten und etwas
verstopfte Nase und
Müdigkeit  Jetzt lösen und
verbessern Ich möchte
Dr. Dooley ansprechen, um einige der
Einzelheiten der Pflege des Präsidenten zu besprechen.
Danke und ähm, guten Tag, ich bin Dr.
Sean Dooley, wie Dr.
Conley erwähnte  Was für
ein unglaublicher,
uh, wie unglaublich stolz ich auf unser medizinisches Team bin, das
sich hinter mir versammelt hat,
und auf die Ehre, den
Präsidenten in den letzten
24 Stunden hier bei Walter Reed zu betreuen. Er
erhält eine hervorragende multidisziplinäre
Versorgung auf
dem neuesten Stand der Wissenschaft für das Coronavirus
Infektion
überwachen wir ihn sehr genau, uh
auf Anzeichen von Komplikationen
entweder durch die Coronavirus-Krankheit oder die
Therapien, die wir verschreiben,
um ihn besser zu machen, die
wir überwachen  d seine Herzfunktion
seine
Nierenfunktion seine Leberfunktion
alle diese sind
normal und der Präsident hat heute Morgen
keinen Sauerstoff, er hat
keine Atembeschwerden oder
läuft herum,
ähm, die medizinische Abteilung des Weißen Hauses oben,
er ist außergewöhnlich guter Laune
und tatsächlich, als wir fertig waren  Unsere
multidisziplinären Runden heute Morgen,
äh, das Zitat, das er uns hinterlassen hat, war, dass ich das
Gefühl habe, heute hier rausgehen zu können, und
das war ein sehr ermutigender
Kommentar des Präsidenten.
Ich werde fortfahren und Dr.
Garabaldi vorstellen, über den ich sprechen werde  Einige
unserer Therapien und der
Pflegeplan für heute.
Danke,
danke, Dr. Dooley, und ich möchte
die Meinung des gesamten Teams wiederholen, was für
eine
Ehre und ein Privileg es ist,
Teil dieser multidisziplinären Einheit zu sein
Betreuung des Präsidenten
Vor etwa 48 Stunden erhielt der
Präsident eine spezielle
Antikörpertherapie gegen das Coronavirus, und
wir arbeiten sehr eng mit dem
Unternehmen zusammen, um ihn zu überwachen
In Bezug auf dieses Ergebnis hat er gestern
Abend seine erste Dosis
Elfenbein-Rem-Verdiener erhalten,
und unser Plan ist es, einen fünftägigen
Behandlungskurs für Rem-Verdiener fortzusetzen,
und der große Plan für heute, da er
so gute Laune hat und es ihm gut geht, ist, ihn zu
ermutigen  Er muss essen
, trinken, hydriert bleiben, aus dem Bett aufstehen
und arbeiten und die Dinge tun, die
er tun muss, um
gesund zu werden. Ich werde Dr. Connolly auf alle
Fragen verweisen,
danke
Brian  über 24 Stunden fieberfrei
bleiben wir vorsichtig optimistisch, aber er
macht sich großartig
damit, oh noch eine Anmerkung, es sollte
klar sein, dass
er viel Arbeit vom Stabschef zu erledigen hat,
und er erledigt es damit, wenn es ein
paar Fragen gibt  über die Gesundheit des Präsidenten,
ähm, in den letzten paar Tagen,
aktuelle Nachrichten, nächstes Video und Vergebung